[Music]
michael is with us in lincoln nebraska
hey michael welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so
we uh we put an offering on a house and
um it was contingent upon us getting the
financing
and we
were
i don't know i guess we thought that our
house would sell in like
24 hours and we thought we were gonna
get you know at least asking price or
that would maybe even escalate
and then several weeks later um we're
getting ready to get to the closing date
here and we haven't even had one offer
on our house i mean we've had
several price reductions we just can't
quite figure out what's going on
we put some money down as an earnest
deposit
and i guess we're just completely lost
on what do we do from here because
they're
recommending a bridge loan and i really
don't want to do a bridge loan and
they're telling us yeah you know you're
going to get approved and it's like well
i don't necessarily want to be approved
because it's going to be
way more than what we're expecting to
pay so i guess
we're just kind of looking for some
advice on on where we go from here we
wish we would have sold the house
before i know i've listened to your
shows and that's what you would have
recommended i didn't even i didn't hear
that piece of the advice but so anyway
we're just kind of
wondering what we do from here and how
you would how you would process this
situation
have you talked to your agent about why
it's not selling i know you said you've
done some price reductions but i mean
has they shot you straight of what they
think it is
you know for like the first two weeks
um
we didn't really get a lot of feedback
uh we're hearing maybe it's the
neighborhood i mean it's not the nicest
part
um
we no we haven't really gotten like
tremendous feedback with the
neighborhood is really pretty much the
only thing we've heard or it's been
people who are just kind of coming in
kicking tires not serious about looking
you know first-time home buyers i mean
we've had
a decent amount of traffic we've had
several home showings a couple of them
were bus but
really we've just heard maybe the
neighborhood we you know we've we've
looked at the comps several times we we
think it's priced accordingly and you
know we've had a seven percent reduction
and even after all the reductions we're
just we're still not getting any
any feedback is it ugly
i mean i mean
let's have a moment like we're trying to
shoot you straight here michael like
what like is it right
i mean
no i don't think everyone who's looked
at it and that's i've tried to get tons
of third-party advice like i'm just i'm
asking people like please just like
shoot me straight i agree with you i'm
like you know like we we've rep we
repainted inside we've lived there we
repainted the outside i mean what uh
what's it on the morning
it was on the market for 225 initially
and now it's on the market for what
209 5.
um
all right and
the other house you paid what for
what'd you pay for it uh we we offered
4.75 and it's not contingent upon the
sale of your home
no
so you have given someone your word to
buy that house
yeah so you'll be closing
you'll be closing on that house because
you gave your word
right
that's the only thing i was that i was
kind of thinking was it is contingent
upon financing but you're right if your
financing doesn't go through
then if they tell you if they turn you
down for the loan due to the fact how
much do you owe on your current home
uh 94.
okay
so the bridge loan would be for your
equity that that's what they're
discussing then
yeah do you have any money for the down
payment if you don't sell your house or
take out a bridge loan
um
our emergency fund yeah then you can you
can close on the deals legally so that's
probably what you're gonna end up doing
okay ask your real estate agent i think
you may need a new real estate agent get
with our endorsed local providers and
ask them what the average days on the
market is and what the average price
range is
i got a feeling it's a 195 sale price
i think you're price tag
when you think a seven percent price
reduction is a big price reduction
uh that you know it's not a big price
reduction
so i i think you're about to sell this
house cheap because you did a deal
poorly that's what it sounds like to me